>>Female presenter: Well, welcome today to
this AuthorsGoogle Talk with John Medina,
who is returning. He was here in 2008, where
he talked about his book Brain Rules, which
is not this one. Welcome, also, to all the
VC locations. We have seven different locations
VC-ing in today. So, with that in mind, when
you do ask your questions, here, locally,
please use the microphone so that they can
hear your questions, and also it will be recorded
for YouTube. So, John who really doesn't need
much of an introduction, is on the faculty
of The University of Washington School of
Medicine in the Bioengineering Department
and is a director of The Brain Center of Applied
Learning Research at Seattle Pacific University.
And he's here today to talk about his book
Brain Rules.
[inaudible.]
Welcome John.
[applause]
>>John: Well, it's a pleasure to be back here
again. Vikki tells me that I can't escape
from this space, so that I can stay glued
to the monitor. If you've heard me speak before,
you know I have a near-Pentecostal style of
teaching. So that will be very difficult to
do, but if, Vikki, if I do wander for a second,
just raise your hand and say, "Medina, would
you get back in front of the camera." And
I'll do my best to stay there. In a minute,
I'm going to reveal to you the number one
question I am asked whenever I give lectures
on in utero brain development for parents.
I'm a Developmental Molecular Biologist by
training. Most of my life has been spent primarily
as a private consultant; mostly to biotech
and pharmaceutical industries. My specialty
is the Genetics of Psychiatric Disorders,
so I'm very interested in what happens when
brains develop in a womb at the level of gene
and cell, and then when things screw up and
you can get a behavioral disorder. So, I spend
a long time thinking about the distance between
a gene and a behavior; primarily as a glorified
troubleshooter. I founded two brain research
institutes along the way and in one in particular,
I would, because they would investigate how
infants process information at cellular, molecular
and behavioral levels, that's where sometimes
I would give talks about in utero brain development
to parents. Actually, the parents to be. This
book comes from a mistake I would make whenever
I would introduce those audiences and talk
to them about brain development. Cause I'd
always start out, you guys, by saying something
like, "Behold, the differential gene transcription
in the developing rhombancephalon." "Take
a look at neuronal cone migration and here
some cells and tasty molecules." And I would
watch my audiences just fade away from me
and I could see a strong distance beginning
to come and then at the very end, I could
see how far I had missed my audiences simply
by the questions I would be asked by these
parents, primarily parents to be; they had
just found out they were pregnant, at the
end of the talk. Quite literally, I would
get the same five questions over and over
again. Question like, "So, how do I get my
kid into Harvard?"
[laughter]
Well, there's nothing wrong with Stanford,
or Berkeley and there's nothing wrong with
the University of Washington, so I think what
they're really asking is, "How is it, I get
my kid to survive a tough, intellectual environment,
given a knowledge-based economy?" I would
get questions like, "Does my kid have an active
mental life in the womb?" "How do I make it
a happy child?" "What is having a baby going
to do with my primary relationship?" Primarily
a marriage. "What's the baby's gonna, having
a baby gonna do to my marriage?" And the heartbreaker
question almost always delivered by a grandmother
who'd gotten custodial authority over her
grandchild, because the daughter was a crack
addict, "Dr. Medina, how do I make a moral
child?" That unexpected nature reminds me
of something that's very much with the heart
and soul of Brain Rules for baby, and that
is the unexpected nature of what parenting
looks like and brain development looks like.
And that reminds me of a very interesting
story about a clinical pediatrician who has
a four year old daughter. And the four year
old daughter was in the back seat of a car.
Good. Strapped into a car seat. And she's
a pediatrician on the clinical faculty of
a medical school. She's driving, stopped at
a light, she's left her stethoscope in the
back seat of the car and as she's stopped
at the light, she looks and sees the little
girl's hand moving over to the stethoscope
and grabbing it. And the mother is going,
"Oh, be still my beating heart. We're going
to have another pediatrician in the household."
And she sees the little girl actually grab
the stethoscope and put it between her ears
just like she should, and now the mom is going,
"Oh, we're only 12 years and an MCAT away
from having a real, life physician in the
household." And she gets quickly disamused
of the attitude when the little girl grabs
the bell of the stethoscope, puts it to her
lips and shouts, "Welcome to McDonalds.
[laughter]
May I take your order, please?"
So, I wrote the book Brain Rules for Baby
in an attempt to address some of this unexpectedness,
and I decided to take my audience's seriously.
I was given an Ivory Tower, they were asking
for Ivory Soap. So, the Ivory Soap questions
look like this, and what produces the organization
of the book. There's an introduction, pregnancy
considerations, relationship considerations,
smart, happy, moral, and the questions that
the book is organized around follow the same
types of questions I always got whenever I
saw that my audiences really weren't interested
in the rhombancephalon. So, number one, "Does
my baby have an active life in the womb?"
"How will bringing this infant home affect
my marriage?" "How do I get my kid into Harvard?"
"How do I raise a happy child?" "How do I
raise a moral child?" And the number one question
I get whenever it is that I'm talking with
audiences, particularly college educated audiences
and particularly technical, sophisticated
audiences with lots of advanced degrees in
the room, is that guy, "How do I get my kid
into Harvard?" "How do I create an intellectual
environment at home that will allow them to
be intellectually successful later on in life?"
And so, I'm gonna talk about that for the
next 45, 50 minutes or so and I'm gonna divide
this lecture into an introduction and three
parts in order to be able to talk to you about
it. So, I will introduce the "Grump Factor"
and in part one we'll talk about the fact
that babies are active learners. Part two,
"What to do before your child comes into the
world," and then in part three, "What to do
before your child comes into a school." We
will emphasize an example in imitation, then
we'll look at the relational ecology of the
home and then, finally, we'll end it out with
effort versus IQ.
Let's start with an introduction, the grump
factor. Hopefully, I'm a nice guy. I'm a pretty
grumpy scientist. I don't have a lot of tolerance
for uncontrollable variables and the first
thing I'm going to say might sound surprising
to you. From the cognitive neurosciences,
it's probably the best academic unit for talking
about parenting and brain science, but if
you've heard me talk before, you already know
what I'm gonna say. I don't think brain science
has anything to do say to how we should raise
our children any more than it had when first
book, Brain Rules, anything about what we
can say about how to educate our kids, or
how to create a great business around it.
There are three reasons for this skepticism
and some of those will sound familiar to you,
too. Reason number one has to do with ignorance.
We don't know very much about how the brain
works, regardless of what you may have heard.
We do not know how you know how to pick up
a glass of water and drink it. We don't know
how it is that you can sign your name. We
don't know why it takes two years for a child
to decide whether they're gonna be right-handed
or left-handed. We don't know squat about
how the brain processes information. We don't
know most of the basics.
Number two: Individuality. This has to do
with the previous brain rule in Brain Rules,
the book. Number three: Every brain is wired
differently from every other brain and learns
in ways unique to that wiring. Kids are extraordinarily
active learners and they learn in actively
wiring themselves differently and the upshot
is, regardless of parenting advice books that
might be out there, one size very seldom fits
all. And as a result of the balkanization
of the individual wiring of the brain, you
have to be very careful, especially if you
want the hard stuff, the neurosciences, to
actually inform your parenting skills. There's
a few out there. We're gonna talk about them,
but there's not very many. One size very seldom
fits all.
Number three: The data. I have some real problems
from the times that it has been researched.
For example, most of the data about parenting
and brains are associative in nature, rather
than causal and that limits much of what you
can say. What I mean by associative is simply
this: all bullies drink fluid. That does not
mean drinking fluid leads to bullying. It's
just that they're co-associated and a lot
of the data in parenting world is a lot like
that and so, you have to be careful with it.
I would also argue this: I'm not sure how
much of the data that's out there, in the
last 30 years, is actually relevant to the
real world of 2010-2011. For example, the
American family is changing in three very
dramatic ways. Number one, you now have blended
families is the norm. Forty percent of all
American children under the age of 15 will
experience a parental break-up by the time
they are 15. Forty percent of all babies born
in 2009 were born to single parent households.
And the 2010 figure's looking larger. There
are gay households. One in five gay couples
are starting a family, yet the data, such
as it exists, primarily has been done with
heterosexual, married couples, most of whom
were white. Well, that's where the data we're
gonna have to mine comes from, but with those
caveats in mind, I can now get into the body
of the talk, but it's my grump factor and
hopefully, you got a pretty good grump factor,
too, and I wanna start that out.
I did write Brain Rules for Baby. There are
some things you can say from the sciences,
but you have to be darn careful with what
you do before you get started. So, if you're
taking notes, and I see some of you are trying,
you already now notice that I speak at the
speed of light. If you still wanna keep your
pencils up, that will be the triumph of hope
over experience, but I wish you well.
[laughter]
Take out your pencils.
Part one: Babies are active learners. Talking
about getting into Harvard, we're gonna talk
about imitation. They are extraordinarily
sensitive to the adult behaviors that surround
them and for that I wanna give you another
example that also comes from a pediatrician.
She has a husband who is a principle investigator
biochemist. Hot dog lab, boy, two NIH program
projects, got lots of post-docs and graduate
students. She's a clinical pediatrician. They
have a six year old daughter and he has a
tradition. Every year he invites, cause a
lot of this post-docs are from South Asia
and the People's Republic of China, he has
a lot of folks who have no place to go for
Christmas. He calls them Christmas orphans,
so he is going to invite them all over for
dinner, which he does. Very delighted. They
have a very traditional marriage, and that's
gonna be important in this story in just a
second. But, the mom who also has a career
and who also has lots of things she's doing,
because it's a traditional marriage, even
though it's his laboratory, guess who has
to do the dinner? She does. She's cooking
the dinner and I will tell you she gets increasingly
pissed off by this as the years have gone
by cause the guys are all talking science
in the den and she's having to do all the
preparations. And the six year old daughter
is observing this anger on the part of "the
wife, mom." And so, it happens and they cook
the dinner and they sit down for table and
she turns to the daughter just before they
all get ready to eat and says, "Honey, six
year old daughter, will you mind saying the
blessing for dinner?" And she goes, "No, Mom,
I do mind. I don't wanna do it." And Mom goes,
"Well, why not, honey" "I'm already stressed
enough," she's thinking to herself, I think.
Daughter goes, "Well, I wouldn't know what
to say." And Mom gets a relaxed look on her
face and says, "That's ok, dear. You just
say what you hear Mommy say."
[laughter]
Little girl gets this wicked look on her face,
apparently, closes her eyes and says, "Oh,
Lord, why did my husband invite all these
jerks to dinner?"
[laughter]
So, they are very sensitive to the adult behaviors
surrounding. That's an example of a six year
old. Believe it or not, we can see this, what
is a very strong form of imitative instincts,
42 minutes after a child has been born. That
imitative behavior, sometimes called reflective
behavior, that imitative behavior can be measured
directly after birth, so we think it may be
innate insofar as post-birth, preloaded software
in a kid is innate. Andy Meltzoff did it.
He had the guts to do this. He had the guts,
at 42 minutes of age, to stick his tongue
out at a baby and then wait. Now that experiment
had probably done before. Philosophically,
in experimental psychology, we used to think
that babies were tabula rasas. What's a tabula
rasa? Blank slate and that you can just paint
your self portrait, as a parent, on the kid's
brain anytime you wanted, probably thought
by a bunch of underfunded experimental psychologists,
none of whom had kids. Because if you have
kids, you realize they come with all kinds
of pre-loaded software and Andy was the first
to really show how sophisticated and active
a learner a baby is just after birth. Forty-two
minutes of age, he sticks his tongue out at
a baby and the waits. And finds a miracle.
The baby sticks its tongue back out at Andy.
Now, that's amazing. Why is that amazing?
Has the baby ever seen a tongue before? No.
Has it ever seen its tongue before? No. Has
it ever seen your tongue, or Andy's tongue,
before? The answer is no. What's it seen for
the last nine months? A pink gauze watery
environment that was increasingly uncomfortable
and it wanted to leave. But knows that after
you've cleaned him up and got the APGAR and
you're looking at him, knows that it has a
tongue, knows that Andy has a tongue and knows
that if it sequences the right amount of neurons
in the right amount of space innervating not
all of the body, but just down through the
lower jaw, will, in fact, stick it's tongue
back out at Andy. That's pre-loaded software.
Now, it takes some time. It takes about 45
seconds and this is an experiment you can
try at home. If you're pregnant, if you've
got, that's the reason why you're here, you've
got small kids at home, you can try this at
home. But it looks a little bit like , show
my age, Joe Cocker at Woodstock, ok? It looks
like this. You go,"Bleh!" And the baby goes,
"Bleh!" Sticks his tongue back out.
[laughter]
Ok? So, you have to wait. You actually have
to have a video tape to be getting it going.
Once we understood that, you can actually
watch this imitative experience begin to develop
over time, and you realize how unbelievably
sensitive that "jerks to dinner" story actually
is. Kids are doing a tremendous amount of
imitation and they are imitating you, parent!
They've got you in their gun sights. And that's
where parenting begins to take on a very interesting
complexion, simply because babies are such
active sponges. Let me give you two examples
of this active sponge business. It's extraordinary
to actually watch. I'd advise you, if you've
not gone on this, if you are pregnant or thinking
about having children, get on truuconfessions.com.
T-R-U-U confessions.com. It will give you
a very interesting active slice of American
parenting. It's essentially an online diary.
You post anonymously and you can just share
your impressions. I've got two impressions
to share with you about, I think one is a
two year old and other is a, they're both
24 months old, to show you how actively these
kids are already mapping; how sophisticated
and developed this tongue sticking out has
actually gotten. Watch this.
[reads]
"My two year old daughter was so cute today.
My husband was watching football and when
his team made a touchdown, he got all excited
and pretended to head butt me, except I didn't
expect it and moved so he ended up doing it
for real. It hurt. While my husband was apologizing
profusely, my daughter brought me her special
blanket she never lets go of and her pacifier
and shoved the pacifier into my mouth--
[laughter]
and made me lie down on her blanket to make
me feel better, LOL."
[chuckles]
Another example.
[reads]
"I have got to learn not to be so crude when
I get home. I was complaining to Shelley on
the phone after work how much of a pain in
the butt my boss is. A few minutes later,
I smelled diaper rash cream, then felt someone
trying to lift up my skirt. My dear two year
old daughter had opened a tube of Desitin
and was trying to smear it on my backside.
I said, 'What in the world are you doing?'
She said, 'Nothing, Mommy. It's for the pain
in your butt.'--
[laughter]
"I love this girl so much I could've squeezed
her till she burst."
There, unbelievable behavioral mappers are
infants. They, you can see it at 42 minutes
of age, you can see it at 24 months of age,
you can see it at 72 months of age. They are
unbelievably sensitive to their environment
and it is that kernel of an idea that I want
to explore to you for some of the things we
can do, if you really are interested in getting
your kid into Harvard. You have to take into
account this sensitivity very, very much and
for that I'm getting into part two of our
discussion. What to do before your child comes
into the world: The relational ecology of
the home.
I have three pieces of unexpected news. That's
a euphemism for bad news, by the way. I have
three pieces of bad news for you expectant
parents and one piece of really good news.
And I want to explore all with you. We're
gonna be talking about what to do before your
child comes into the world. You found out
you were pregnant, what's gonna happen to
your marriage, what's gonna happen to you
when the pregnancy comes, and fine. Ok, number
one piece of bad news. Marital conflict increases
in the transition to parenthood. I suggest
you get ready for it. By the time the kid
is six months of age, it either increases
two-fold or nine-fold, depending on the study.
There are several. You can say that it just
increases dramatically. Number two, kids can
sense the increase even as infants, because
of that sensitivity we were talking about,
and will rewire their nervous systems in response.
Number three, this rewiring can interfere
with their academic performance later in life.
So, there's three pieces of bad news, or unexpected
news. Now for the piece of good news. The
effect does not have to be permanent. In fact,
there are data that suggests that it's actually
not the amount of marital conflict, the amount
of fighting between partners that actually
rewires the kid's nervous system; it's the
loss of the ability for the child to see resolving
behavior. Do you understand? You can actually
fight all you want, but if you don't resolve
in front of your kids in a fashion they can
actually see that everything is gonna be all
right and you now have an asymmetric perception
of the emotional ecology of the home, you
will rewire that kids nervous system in a
way that does not aid and abet their progress
into Harvard. So, the whole idea is don't
have that asymmetry. So, many couples will,
maybe sometimes fights are like that. You
start like a rock on a hill and it's gonna
roll down and the kid is there, and you don't
mean to, but you end up fighting and it's
12 midnight before the resolution finally
occurs, and you go to your spouse and you
say, "Honey, I'm so sorry. I didn't mean to
do that." And you resolve and your relationship's
gonna be intact, which is fine, but the kid
never sees it. And it's that asymmetry that
is the killer. So, there's good news; you
don't have to have this. But, unpack everything
I've just said, let's take a look at this
and then we will discuss in some detail that
important idea, ok? Number one, marital conflict
increases in the transition to parenthood.
It does. Kids can sense the increase, even
as infants, and rewire their nervous systems
in response. And number three, this rewiring
can interfere with their academic performance
later in life and the turquoise says that
this effect does not have to be permanent.
So, let's get into it. What does this do to
the kid and what kinds of conflict is available?
Let's take a look first at distress rates.
Here's a tasty reference for you. Alrighty,
what we're gonna take a look at in the transition
to parenthood is stable relationship. Here's
the birth of the baby. Here is the hostility
and it goes way, way up. Yup. By the time
the baby is born, marital satisfaction yarooon
way, way down. Folks, that's relative instability.
[laughter]
But we had no idea how unstable things could
be. It plummets anywhere from 67% to 90%,
depending upon the study that you're reading.
I'm a conservative scientist, so we'll go
with the 67, but that does mean that two-thirds
of all couples are having some problems by
the time their one and only has landed on
the planet. In such fashion, you can actually
measure it, these things, through SPF Tests
and a variety of hostility indices that we
can measure in the laboratory. Let's take
a look at a non-distressed couple. Let's take
a look at a distressed couple in therapy,
trying to save their relationship. And then
let's take a look at the hostility index of
a couple who has their first child and the
child is now one year old. What do you see
in terms of NHI? Well, this is what you see.
There's your non-distressed couple. There's
your distressed couple in trouble. And here's
a non-distressed couple who's had their first
child. Wow. If it's going to come to you that
this will happen, what will it do to the kid's
nervous system if you don't do something?
We're gonna talk about what to do. But, this
is what happens. Now, I realize that not all
of you are molecular neurobiologists for sure,
so let's just make sure we've done some human
anatomy to talk a little bit about what actually
happens. You can divide the nervous system
into two parts; central or peripheral. Central
is brain and spinal column; peripheral nervous
system is everything else. You can take the
peripheral and further subdivide it into autonomic
and somatic nervous system. Autonomic measures
stress, amongst other things, and the somatic
system generally is innervating skeletal muscles.
That's not completely true. And then if you
take and do this autonomic nervous system,
see that word? For those of you who can't
read it, that word says stress, amongst other
things. If you then take and ask the question,
"What's it doing to the nervous system?" I
have to subdivide that guy into two parts,
so I'm going to. The autonomic nervous system
can be divided into the sympathetic nervous
system and parasympathetic nervous system.
In, on average, the sympathetic nervous system
stimulates many stress responses. The parasympathetic
nervous system tells the sympathetic nervous
system to shut up. All right? So, it's gonna
try and regulate it. Now, that's not completely
true, there's actually equilibrium between
these two, but there are some, not to take
the nuances only for much, but you can think
of this as something that stimulates and something
that tries to tell it to shut up. So, you're
gonna look for some emotional regulation and
to do that, to understand the neurobiology
of that, I've gotta introduce to you one last
term. How many of you have heard of cranial
nerves before? Have you heard of cranial nerves
before? Ok, we're gonna talk, for those of
you who have, we're gonna talk about the tenth
cranial nerve, called the vagus nerve, because
the vagus nerve is going to take and respond
and traffic between sympathetic and parasympathetic
actually pretty well. So, we're gonna take
a look at it. Sympathetic nervous system and
parasympathetic. Sympathetic is gonna mediate
your stress responses, so it's gonna be, regulate
heart, respiration, appetite, cortisol, digestion
and so on. And the parasympathetic is gonna
tell it to shut up, or at least try to. It's
gonna have regulatory potentiometers, only
by analogy, that you can look at. And the
potentiometers are, in fact, the vagus nerve
and it's a very complex system, but we know
a fair amount about it, so much so we can
actually measure it. If the kid is going to
be emotionally stable this interaction is
gonna work beautifully. And if the kid is
gonna be a basket case, he can't tell his
stress responses to shut up. We call that
vagal tone. You got high vagal tone; you got
a kid who's emotionally right on. You got
a low vagal tone, you got a kid who does not
regulate their own emotional responses very
well and I'm here to tell you that if you
have lots of asymmetric combat in your household,
you will create kids with lower vagal tone,
statistically. In fact, the whole thing looks
like this and I'll give you a reference for
it.
[clears throat]
Ok, here's our tenth cranial nerve and what
we're going to be looking at, whoopsie, sorry,
it's this guy right here. Here we go. Alrighty.
There's our reference. What unresolved marital
conflict does to a child's nervous system.
Alrighty. If you have unresolved marital conflict,
there's a greater incidence of pediatric depression
and anxiety disorders, greater prevalence
of antisocial behavior in school, poor emotional
regulation, more infectious diseases, that's
because you're collapsing part of the immune
response, poor executive function, which we're
gonna get into, that's where it gets the poorest
grades and then you've got your vagal tone
problems. You've got differences in parasympathetic/sympathetic
interactions, ok? Not so good news.
Is there anything you can do about it? The
answer is yes, depending upon the following.
Researchers began to investigate this question.
Well, if it's so toxic, this marital conflict
business, what do married couples fight about?
And remember, I have to stay with the data,
so I'm literally talking about married couples.
What do married couples fight about in the
transition to parenthood? Well, it falls on
gender lines, believe it or not. And to do
that, we have to enter into a whole thicket
of psychosocial versus genetic issues. There
are many more social, cultural influences
on gender specific behavior than there are
genetic ones. In fact, I tend to map them.
If you wanna see what I think are the social
prejudices, there are social prejudices against
females, there's social prejudices against
males, and I decided to map them one time.
Here are, is an FMRI of the social prejudices
of the female brain. Here we go. Her instinct
to use the ladies room, sense of direction
particle, irrational thoughts, need to discuss
feelings nucleus, argue and debate lobe, sex
particle, chocolate center, weigh all options
a hundred freaking times, need for commitment
hemisphere, shopping and indecision. There's
the social prejudices of the female brain.
And so then I will ask my audiences, "Would
you like to see the male prejudices of the
male brain?" Socialize, and then most of themthey
say, "Yes." And so I say, "Ok, I would be
happy to show them to you." There it is.
[laughter]
So, we're gonna be talking about gender line
specific behaviors, I actually call them in
the book "the four grapes of wrath." These
are the four things, there are statistical
clusters of behaviors, of things we know that
married couples fight about in the transition
to parenthood. And here are the four grapes
of wrath, and we're gonna go through one of
them, ok? I can't go through all four; we
won't have time. But we can certainly can
go through one. Sleep loss, social isolation,
prevalence of affective disorders and chore
inequities. Good grief. Ok, sleep loss. I
haven't had a good night's sleep in six months.
That's a very common behavior for those of
you who are rookie parents; finding out that
you're pregnant and you're gonna have a baby,
ok? Social isolation. Where did all my friends
go? Why don't I have the energy to see them?
Affective disorders. Sometimes, I sleep in
my car, alone. Affective disorders are things
like anxiety and depressive disorders. Depression
skyrockets in many, both men and women, actually,
with the birth of a baby. And then finally,
chore inequities. My husband doesn't want
to help me with the house or the baby; he
just plays World of Warcraft all day.
[laughter]
All right? So, with these in mind, I'm gonna
talk about not all of these, but I'm gonna
talk about one of them because it suggests
something very practical to do and here's
a reference for you. If you are having a baby
and you're in the transition to parenthood,
we're gonna talk about chore inequities to
show that we have a very specific gender bias.
The percent of all household chores, dishes,
dirt, diapers, minor household repairs, car
issues, food acquisition preparation, whether
mom is working in the house or not, 1978 statistic
and 2008 statistic. If you are a male, fasten
your seatbelts.
[laughter]
All right? Let's take a look at chore disparities.
1978 versus 2008. In 1978, it's a 15 to 85
split, with mom doing it, even if she's working,
oddly enough. And in 2008, especially if she's
working, it's gone up, but it's a little better,
but no one's gonna call this even; it's a
30, 70 split. And if you look particularly,
I think, one of the most damning of the statistics
is this. Having a husband around actually
creates an extra seven hours of work per week
for women
[laughter]
and a wife saves her husband about one hour
of work per week. Nobody, it's nice that it's
improving, nobody's gonna call that equal
and if we can hear from our friends, once
again, from truuconfessions.com, we get the
following.
[reads]
"If my husband tells me one more time that
he needs to rest because he quote, 'worked
all day,' I will throw all of his clothes
on the front lawn, kick his car into neutral
and watch it roll away and I'll sell all of
his precious sports stuff on eBay for a dollar
and then I'll kill him."
[laughter]
"He seriously doesn't get it. Yeah, he worked
all day, but he worked with English speaking,
potty trained adults."
[laughter]
"He didn't have to change their diapers, give
them naps and clean their lunch from the wall.
He didn't have to count to ten to calm himself.
He didn't have to watch Barney 30 million,
three hundred and 24 thousand freaking times
and he didn't have to pop his boob out six
times a day to feed a hungry baby and I know
he didn't have peanut butter and jelly crust
for lunch."
If you are going to have a baby, and that
is a part of your household, then statistically,
in the United States, it is, I have a suggestion
for you. Besides learning how to resolve in
front of your children, make two lists before
the baby comes. List A, everything wife does
in the house. List B, everything husband does
in the house. If those are unequal, you change
your behavior and make it equal before they
come. And it's the oddest thing to say that
that's one of the biggest sources of marital
conflict that exists in the transition to
parenthood and if you can rewire a kid's nervous
system, based on the amount of unresolved
conflict that's there, you come to an astonishing
and odd conclusion. You wanna get your kid
into Harvard, guys? Learn how to clean the
toilet.
[laughter]
Ok, well. Here's our chore solution right
here. Ok, here's our two lists. Here's your
household or your apartment or your dwelling
place, your domicile. List A, all the chores
wife does. List B, all the chores the husband
does. And that says, "If list A does not equal
list B, then equalize it before the baby comes."
All right. That's what cognitive neuroscience
has to say.
[laughter]
Not exactly a 4A transform off a 4 Tesla fMRI,
is it? Part three, what to do when your child
comes into a school.
[coughs]
Excuse me. And the subtitles you might remember
is effort versus IQ, right? Effort versus
IQ. This is what you do before the kid is
pregnant; learn how to fight friendly and
learn how to clean up around the house, but
what do you do before the kid goes in the
school system? The book really does transit
between zero and five years of age, and so
I would like to talk a little bit about that.
To talk about effort versus IQ. I wanna give
you an example of what I mean by effort. My
mom, a 4th grade teacher, was a specialist
in effort. She loved to give her budding scientist
child brain teasers, but she would never give
me the answer, darn it. She had me do effort.
So, she really never, ever gave me the answers
and I never knew whether she couldn't get
the answers, which wasn't likely, she's really
smart, or whether she had something of a very
interesting insight. I'll give you an example
of a puzzle she gave me, and because she's
a teacher, she actually had access to certain
psychometric tests. This is actually a test
you can use in the laboratory. It's called
Gist and detail test as a function of resolution.
It's measuring what we call fluid intelligence
of a sort. I'll give it to you. You guys can
figure this out in ten seconds. It took me
about a minute, but here it is. Go ahead and
tackle that for a second. I think you can
probably see this, but I'll read it to you
for those of you in the back who might not
read it.
[reads from screen]
"There are are three things wrong wrong with
this sentence. Can you find them?"
Ok. Go ahead. "There are are three things
wrong wrong with this sentence. Can you find
them?" Ok? And I, as a little boy, would look
at that. It didn't take me all that long for
this one. It takes amount of effort, but I
didn't get it instantly. Ok? I would look
at it and say, "Hmmm." How many of you found
the, you can find two of them easy enough,
you found the third one alright? Yeah? Ok,
maybe a quarter of you. Ok. All right. I'll
go through this. "There are are three things
wrong wrong with this sentence." Well, the
hint is in the Gist versus detail; 40 thousand
foot view versus the 10 micron view. What
are you gonna take a look at? Well, I can
see two, I would reason. I could see two things
wrong with this because they're repeating
two words. "There are are," that's one error.
"Three things wrong wrong," that's a second
error with the sentence and then all of a
sudden it would hit me by effort. Wow. There
are two things wrong with the sentence, but
the sentence says there are three things wrong
with this sentence. There are not three things
wrong with this sentence. There are only two
things wrong with this sentence. The whole
freaking sentence is wrong.
[laughter]
And I would look at that and I would say,
"Mom, you son of a gun." Effort versus IQ.
And then she'd give me a chaser, you guys.
She's a gentle soul, after all. And it's my
favorite book of all time, this is a game,
book says, "Games you can't lose," so these
require no efforts and she just gave this
to me, I think, as a chaser just to make sure
I wouldn't be defeated by, this is my favorite
book of all time. "Bobbing for water." Well,
that's a game you can't lose. "Can you help
Fred find the pizza?" That's a game you can't
lose. And my favorite, cause it's so darn
existential, "Connect the dot."
[laughter]
So, we've got effort versus IQ to talk about.
And to talk about what to do before your kid
enters the school in such fashion that if
Harvard is your option, or better to say an
intellectually robust environment is, we have
to turn to, of all people, somebody who is,
where is Stanford, please, from here? Just
point. Is it just that way? It's still somewhere
that way? This is the land of Carol Dweck.
How many of you are familiar with Carol Dweck?
A few of you? All right. For those of you
who aren't, you can try and sa-, she did not
tackle the problem this way, but I'll couch
it this way and then bring up Carol's terrific
work. You know, let's say you did your job
well and your kid got into Harvard or Princeton
or Stanford or wherever you think is a hot
shot place, what you can see, I'm using Harvard
as my metaphor here, what you can see is you
see two feeder types in the first year of
Harvard life. Number one, some kids make it
just fine. They do very well, but that's not
true of all of the cohorts. Some get crushed
by the experience, and they end up leaving
before the first year is over. And they have
high depressive disorders, maybe, sometimes
anxiety disorders. They're not doing very
well in intellectually tough environments
and the question you can ask is, assuming
a certain level of IQ, or a certain level
of accomplishment at least, what's up with
that? How come you got two and not one? Well,
Carol thinks she's got a good answer for it,
and boy, I agree with her. Here it is. She
was able to show that over the arching period
of your parenting skill, 15 to 20 year period,
it fully depended on how you praised or faulted
your child's intellectual accomplishment.
And I'm gonna go over that in some detail.
And then I'll be done and then I'll take questions.
It fully depended on how you, as a parent,
reacted to your kid's intellectual successes
and failures. Here's what you shouldn't do.
It's a cluster of behavior that is so robust
and available; she's actually it with a name.
It's called FMS, fixed mindset behaviors,
if you wanna look this up, ok? I'll provide
a reference in a second. Fixed mindset behaviors.
You really wanna get your kid crushed by Harvard?
Do this: little Johnny gets an A. You'll say
three things. Little Johnny comes in and you
found he's got an A. "Little Johnny, you got
an A. I'm so proud of you. You're so smart."
That sounds lovely. That sounds encouraging.
It is, in fact, toxic. Here's why. What happens
over the course of a multi-year period is
this. The kid gets it that I get good grades
because I'm so smart, but what is smart? Well,
even in the laboratory for us, we have no
idea what intelligence is. Like I said, we
don't even know how you know how to write
your name. Its ephemeral, it's amorphous;
we don't know what intelligence is. Little
Johnny doesn't know what it is, but you know,
I get an A because I'm smart. Well, what happens
when Little Johnny gets a C? If I got an A
cause I am so smart, I got a C because I am
stupid. Yeah. And over the course of years,
you see an extraordinary reaction in households
where kids are constantly being fed fixed
mindset behaviors, which is what she calls
them, FMS. They get an astonishing lack of
tenacity. They wilt in the face of challenging
problems. They don't do very well at all because
they can't control it. Well, I got an A cause
I'm smart, but sometimes I get these Cs and
I don't know why I get these Cs. I must be
really stupid. I think I'm gonna go away and
hide. In my experience, this is not Carol's
work, this is just John Medina's comment on
it, I have seen many fixed mindset households
over the years since Carol's published this
and you know what I see? I see a lot of parents
treat their kids as if they were merit badges.
Do you know what I mean by merit badge? Whereby
your, their intellectual success is a direct
reflection on you. They're not even in the
picture. The kid doesn't even matter. It's
just a reflection of who you are. And parents
in those households track their kid's GPAs
like they watch their stock portfolios, and
watch what happens when they do. In a fixed
mindset household, we know what they do. Here
is an initial reaction to a hard problem,
reaction to failure and the depth of their
understanding or lack thereof understanding.
Excuse me a second while I go to standard
view for a second. Here we go. Fixed mindset
behaviors. Right here. They panic in reaction
to a hard problem. In their reaction to failure,
they see errors as personal failings. Of course,
they were told they were, are smart, or were
dumb. So, they ruminate on them over and over
again. The depth of understanding is superficial;
the goal appears to be pleasing an authority
figure with a depth of knowledge. They're
not tenacious; they give up much more easily
and that's probably the reason why they get
crushed at Harvard. Not only do they have
no idea what to do, they have every idea that
it could cast dispersion on them. They've
never learned to focus and drill down hard.
They are a product of fixed mindset behavior.
You wanna get your kid to flunk out of Harvard?
By all means, tell them they're smart.
[pause]
Now, there is good news here. You'll notice
I got a little yellow up there with the reference.
It says, "GMS- growth mindset behaviors."
Carol was also able to show something else.
That investigating the type of kids who did
make it very well in intellectually challenging
environments, who did very well, had parents
who constantly deployed over a multi-year
period growth mindset behaviors. And these
growth mindset behaviors ended up being pretty
good. This is what you should do if you wanna
get your kid to survive an intellectually
challenging environments. It's the dangdest
thing. I'll give you the example of kids growing
up in what I'll call the secret sauce of Harvard,
ok? Growth mindset behavior. Little Johnny
gets an A. "Little Johnny, you got an A. I'm
so proud of you. You must have studied really
hard."
[pause]
You see the difference? They're not even in
the same emotional universe, are they? "I
studied really hard. That's why I got an A."
Deploy that over a long period of time and
what you'll see is this. They get it that
I got an A because I studied really hard,
well, when they get a C, if I got an A cause
I studied really hard, if I get a C, it's
because I what? Didn't study hard enough.
And parents in growth mindset households and
my experience, now this is not Carol's work,
this is John's comment on it again, I have
seen that parents in these households actually
teach their kids how to focus, and they almost
ignore their GPAs. It's the dangdest thing.
They don't really care about how their kid's
do as a function of some benchmark; they care
if their kids are applying effort. And when
you do that, you will generate the type of
student that will be welcome in my laboratory
any day because their attitude towards a challenging
problem is, "Yippee! Let's go find out." And
they do not panic simply because they have
faced a goliath. Looks like this. In the GMS
households that are available, growth mindset,
they are relaxed. Often feels delighted with
a challenge in response to a hard problem.
Their reaction to failure? Well, they perceive
errors as problems to be solved, not as personal
problems; not some cancer that's somehow in
them. Their depth of understanding, this is
why I want them in my laboratory, they aren't,
they go deep. Their goal appears to be focused
on solving problems, not impressing authority
figures. They are tenacious; they don't give
up readily. That's why I want them around,
mostly been a consultant most of my life and
I'm consulting with lots of labs and I can
almost pick out the graduate students that
are, that have been grown up in fixed mindset
households versus those that have grown up
in growth mindset households. You grow up
in growth mindset households, you are fundamentally
curious about learning. You grow up in a fixed
mindset household, in my opinion, you don't
care about learning; you care about pleasing.
[pause]
All of a sudden, we not only have things in
the cognitive neurosciences to say about cleaning
the toilet and fighting fair in front of kids,
but in what to do if you really want them
to survive in the coming economies in the
next decades. You don't tell them they're
smart, you guys. You tell them they work hard.
Now, I'm closing, I'll take some questions.
I'm no parenting expert. I'm a brain jock,
a consultant. I probably can't take individual
questions about your child, so it's my way
of abdicating anything that I can't figure
out. I consider parenting to be an amateur
sport. Let me read to you the last page of
the book and then I'm gonna take some questions.
And apparently, you'll need to go to the microphones
for that. Ok, here it is. It's my summary
statement of parenting all in fact. Well,
even though I've been cloning genes out of
brains for a couple of decades now.
[reads]
"In the messy world of child rearing, it can
be startling how profoundly a two-way street
a parent/child social contract really is.
You may think that grown-ups create children.
The reality is that children create grown-ups.
They become their own person and so do you.
Children give a lot more than they take. This
hit me one night when my wife and I were snuggling
with our younger pre-schooler, putting him
to bed. My wife hugged him and thought he
felt like soft bread dough. She said to him,
'Oh, Noah, you're just so squeezable and soft
and delicious.' "
Sounds like a Charmin commercial, doesn't
it?
" 'Oh, Noah, you're just so squeezable and
soft and delicious. I could almost take a
bite out of you. You're so yummy.' Noah responded,
'I know, Mommy. I've really got to lower my
carbs.'
[laughter]
"We laughed till we cried. Seeing his personality
blossom was such a gift. This is the message
I would like to leave with you as I close."
Now, this is at the back of the book, but
I think it's relevant here, too.
[reads]
"As a parent, you may feel sometimes that
all children do is take from you, but it's
just a form of giving in disguise. Kids present
you with an ear infection, but what they are
really giving you is patience. They present
you with a tantrum, but they are really giving
you the exquisite experience, challenging
experience, hardest experience in the world,
of witnessing a developing personality. In
the twinkling of an eye, you realize the great
privilege it is to be the temporary steward
of another life. Before you know it, you've
raised up another human being where there
was once only a point of view. I said that
parenting is all about developing human brains."
Which is something I say a lot in the book.
"But my aim was inches too high. Parenting
is all about developing human hearts. At the
end of the day, it doesn't really matter if
your kids get into Harvard because parenting
isn't a matter of celebrating report cards.
It is a matter of celebrating relationships.
There is no idea in this book, or this talk,
more important than that one."
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Ok, I'll take question-, woah, sorry Vikki.
I'll take questions and comments till 2, and
then you guys are outta here at 2 o'clock,
so you may need to use the microphone. So,
if there are any questions or comments I can
take, fire away.
[pause]
>>female staff: There's one question online.
>>John: Ok.
>>female staff: The person, M, asks, "Does
constant positive reinforcement impact our
kids positively or negatively?"
>>John: Yeah, it's a great question. The question
is about constant reinforcement, positive
reinforcement. Constant positive reinforcement
is a very good thing, but I would also argue
that it is not the only tool kit you need
to have in your parenting supply. There is
a great researcher by the name of Diana Baumrind,
came up with what she says is the ultimate
style of parenting and she actually calls
it authoritative parenting. It is a deep supply
of positive empathy and it's got [inaudible]
in it in lots of places. But, if you look
at households where they have high functioning,
emotionally regulated kids doing very, very
well, who actually get very good grades and
fewer infectious diseases; there are very
clear rules and expectations in the household.
Do you know that? So, it isn't just about
positive reinforcement, it's also ability
to produce boundaries. I think of them a lot
like the banks of a river; the boundaries
that you give your kids. If you have the banks
of a river, you can give them guidance and
whatnot. Those banks in these households are
made out of titanium. They're almost not moveable.
So, you have this interesting balance between
warmth and praise, as the question suggests,
and it's strong there, but also the strong
sense that you know, we've got some rules
here in the family and you can't violate them.
And we're gonna get them strong enough that
there will be both rewards and punishments
for it if you either exceeded the rule or
fail a rule. Those produce the best kids,
statistically, according to Diana Baumrind.
Yeah, go ahead.
>>Male member #1: So, hello. So, I've got
a, she's almost one, at home, and I notice
a lot of times she'll do something and it's
something good and then she'll look and she's
waiting for the praise.
>>John: Uh-huh.
>>Male member #1: How do I get her so she's,
she's interested in doing things, good things,
on her own and not doing it for the praise?
That's something I've been concerned with
at home.
>>John: I see. Well, I would not stop the
praise one iota. She's looking for approval,
she's looking for safety, she's looking for
all kinds of things. Eventually, she will
get recursive on her own. I think you know
what I mean by that, but for a period of time,
particularly in the first year of life, they're
still working out safety issues and so there's
attachment things that are going on and they
wanna look to you and see, "Is this ok that
I still do this?" And if you say, "Yeah, it's
ok that I still do this. Yeah, it's still
ok," there is an envelope, not of dependence
that is growing, but of safety that is growing.
So, I would argue, particularly in the first
year of life, you pour it on. You're not ready
yet, the kid'll go, if you will, self-independent
on her own. Wait till you get, wait for a
year from now--
[laughter]
when you get what's something called the terrible
twos. You will long for this day.
[John laughs]
It'll be just fine.
>>Male member #1: Ok, great.
>>John: Yeah, you bet.
>>Male member #2: I'm wondering about the,
although it's extreme as saying, "You did
well cause you're smart or you do well cause
you worked hard." And if you say, "I'm really
proud of you. You did well cause you worked
hard," the kid might know better. Its like,
"I sailed through that. I didn't have to do
squat."
>>John: Uh-huh[laughs]
>>Male member #2: Yeah.
>>John: Well, then they need to go to another
school.
[laughter]
It's actually a very good point because there
will be a point, particularly, I call it the
BS meter, or the authenticity meter might
be a better way to say it, the, there will
be a point when you'll look at them and they
will say, "Oh, you've studied really hard,"
and the kid goes, "No, I didn't." And if that's
the case, the bar needs to go up. It does.
The point of being able to see, or at least
if you want the assay to see this, you see
this best in problems where they are challenged,
and if they're not challenged enough, then
give them so their intellectual elbow grease
can really get started. So, I would actually
argue that it's gonna be a give and take and
parts of those, that bar probably need to
be raised. Yeah.
Uh-huh, all right, folks. Have a great day.
See you later.
[applause]